Pete Davidson reveals he's been
receiving death threats over ariana
grande celebs go aged over Beyonce and
jay-z and the Riverdale fellas tease at
tonk season 3 scoop
oh what a weekend it was in Los Angeles
guys mom and dad aka Beyonce and jay-z
were in town
you won't believe who else caught the
tour of course let's get into Pete
Davidson the dude got candid during a
stop by at the Howard Stern Show
revealing that since he and ariana
grande became engaged the online abuse
has gotten so bad he's had to quit the
internet yeah I got a death threat
because I want it so in order to shoot
me in the face like a legitimate because
she's so hot well of course you know
saying that is like am i bad ugly if you
want to shoot me in the face like no
this guy what I do now Pete seems to
take it in stride at least on camera but
admit it it's pretty rough it's like the
walking dead out there you know we just
talked to Pete's fellow SNL castmate
Kenan Thompson who gave us a little more
insight on what it's like for the future
mr. grande these days like to see Pete
you know be happy he goes through so
much you know I mean it's hard being
like a millennial on social media and
all of that so he's like just exposed to
a lot of like criticism or like you know
indirect negativity or whatever but like
he handles it really well you know he
believes in his like voice and his
stand-up and it's like I don't give her
attitude or whatever like be able to
Staten Island and all of that he's proud
of that so I feel like he's got a solid
head on his shoulders but to see him
with know a better half of himself and
like making him happy like that is
really nice it's nice but you know what
don't get a twist there guys
Ariana's lucky to a source told et Pete
has been a huge support for her since
Mac Miller's passing and that Ari has
leaned on her fiance for support and now
her friends have a different view on
their future together they have a
stronger bond
now speaking of bond Beyonce and jay-z
are better than ever putting their love
on full display this weekend for their
la Tour stop I was there losing my wig I
mean just look at her here you'll
remember last week we reported that
beyonce is being sued by her former
drummer for extreme witchcraft and you
know what maybe beyonce is a witch
because that was some sorcery that I
witness up on that stage
but you know I wasn't the only one there
there were some famous members of the
Beehive who came to see the couple slay
the Rose ball among them
Oprah she was there with dusty Gayle
King right here just enjoying us she put
a nice weekend norm on he was in the
crowd on Sunday watching her Idol along
with openers Chloe and Halle and some of
their grown ish co-stars but check this
out Kim Kardashian was getting her life
at the concert with her sister Courtney
that's them dancing a Paris which Jay
did with her hubby Kanye who was not
there Kim had another run-in though with
Kylie's ex Tyga that's right Kim was
also there with her mom Kris Jenner and
they ran into him in the pit section now
Tyga I just hit the stage during DJ
Khaled's opening simply it's all good
you guys can tell from here it looks
beat free they swapped a couple of big
smiles during the interaction but that's
what Beyonce and jay-z do they bring
people together but the Beehive is to
music as river babes are to TV because
fans of Riverdale they're getting hype
guys season 3 premieres October 10 on
the CW and only we were with the cast
backstage at the iHeartRadio Festival in
Vegas about what we can expect in the
new season I don't want to shock you got
to ask you about season 3 what can you
tease what's gonna happen to our cheese
we start off we start off our cheese
important we're gonna see if he goes to
jail he dies but I can't tell you if he
goes in on I've heard that the season 3
is going to be very hot and heavy what
can you tell us about that there are
some hot and heavy moments that's for
sure for sure heavy I don't know but it
gets high it is the hottest summer in
Riverdale actually what if you could
describe a season 3 in a couple words
other than hot and heavy what would you
tell the fan deep dark dangerous they
gonna react how much are they gonna
freak out they're gonna freak oh they're
gonna absolutely just freaking out man
it's gonna be knowledge it's crazy dark
and you guys are reading these scripts
what's going through your head I run the
CW that's crazy work that's what CW
stands crazy you work
ask there's a lot of love in the water
over there in Vancouver or Camilla and
Charles stating what's happening guys
Charles is he in town south Melton oh I
think me and Charlie many tiles Archie
dated you tell us just about
artistically what was going through a
head when you recreated that mirror
photo it was really perfect I Casey came
up with the idea we were both of my
trailer and he said take your shirt off
jump on that chair and let me snap it
off it was just like that and he
followed my orders as he always does
last question what are you guys most
excited to see for fans I know you can't
tell me everything but what are you most
excited for the fans to see season 3
storyline wise for each of you I can't
wait for them to see KJ's yeah KJ's
stuff for sure yeah yeah I think Cajun
actually have some cool [ __ ] we other
which has been really fun really
difficult to shoot a serious sizable
scenes to shoot because we can laugh too
hard but it's fun it's really fun
alright guys real talk I never finished
season 2 so I need to get on it but
that's it for today be sure to check out
our backstage interview with Kelly
Clarkson I heart she actually gets
emotional talking about Carrie Underwood
and it's pretty sweet alright
[Music]